>> Sean: ROW ACTION FROM TOJTD’S
OPENING MONOLOGUE, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTER SARA CARTER.
LEGAL ANALYST GREGG JARRETT.
FOS NEWS NATIONAL SECURITY
STRATEGIST SEBASTIAN GORKA.
GREGG, I’LL LET YOU RESPOND.
THE ONLY THING SHOCKING TO ME IS
THAT ANYBODY IS SHOCKED BECAUSE
WE HAVE BEEN TEG EVERYBODY ABOUT
RUSSIA’S WORK INFLUENCE, DIRTY
DEEDS IN THE COUNTRY FOR A LONG
TIME.
THE REST OF THE MEDIA HAS BEEN
LITERALLY IGNORING THE BIGGEST
STORY IN THEIR LIFE IF THEY CAN
OPEN THEIR EYES.
>> THIS SHOULDN’T COMES ON A
SURPRISE TO ANYBODY WHO HAS READ
THE DNI REPORT THAT CAME OUT A
YEAR AGO IN JANUARY.
WHICH THEY DETAIL OVER THE
COURSE OF DECADES THE RUSSIANS
AND BEFORE THEM THE SOVIET’S
EFFORTS TO SEW DISCORD AND
DISRUPTION AND CHAOS IN
DEMOCRACIES ESPECIALLY AMERICA.
WHY, THEY’RE AN AUTHORIZE
TEARIAN GOVERNMENT THAT HATES
DEMOCRACIES.
YOU COULD HEAR THE GROWN ACROSS
THE NATION FROM DEMOCRATS AND
THE LIBERAL MEDIA, SO
DISAPPOINTED WHEN ROSENSTEIN
STEPPED TO THE PODIUM HE SAID
NOT A WORD ABOUT TRUMP-RUSSIAN
COLLUSION.
THE PHISH HAS BEEN AT IT FOR A
YEAR AND A HALF, FOUND NOT A
SHRED OF IT.
MULE HEARS BEEN AT IT SINCE LAST
MAY AND APPARENTLY HASN’T FOUND
ANY EVIDENCE OF IT.
DON’T BE SURPRISED BY WHAT
HAPPENED TODAY.
THIS DOESN’T MEAN THAT MUELLER
IS SHIFTING AWAY FROM TRUMP.
HIS EYES ARE SQUARELY ON DONALD
TRUMP F THEY CAN’T FIND EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION, MUELLER WILL
LIKELY TRY TO PURSUE A CASE OF
OBSTRUCTION.
WHICH DOESN’T APPLY.
>> Sean: LET’S SEE THE COMEY
MEMOS.
HE SAID EXHIBIT A, FOR THE
DEFENSE, EXKWUL PATRY ROW, LEASE
THEM.
>> I’M SURE IT IS EXCULPATORY.
COMEY WAS WRITING THEM, HE
DIDN’T ENVISION BEING FIRED.
HE’S AN ARROGANT GUY AND NEVER
OCCURRED THAT HE WOULD BE.
ALTHOUGH HE CERTAINLY DESERVED
TO BE.
>> Sean: SARA, END OF THE DAY,
RUSSIANS ACTUALLY CAMPAIGNED FOR
AND AGAINST DONALD TRUMP IN THIS
WHOLE THING.
WHAT AN IRONY.
THEY WANTED TO SEW DISCORD, JUST
LIKE THEY WERE ABLE TO
MANIPULATE AMERICA AND THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION TO GET 20% OF OUR
URANIUM EVERYONE ELSE IGNORES.
>> WELL THIS IS WHAT THEY DO.
THIS IS THE RUSSIAN MODUS
OPERANDI, ANYBODY THAT WORKS IN
INTELLIGENCE UNDERSTANDS THIS.
THIS WILL GO BEYOND THE 16-COUNT
INDICTMENT REVEALED THEY WERE
DOING IT BACK IN 2014 AS FAR AS
OUR ELECTION SYSTEM.
BUT I THINK WHAT WE’LL DISCOVER
IS THAT THE DOSSIER WAS ALSO
PART OF THEIR DISINFORMATION
COME PAIN.
CAMPAIGN.
THE RUSSIANS WORKED TO PASS
DISINFORMATION TO CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, UTILIZING FUSION GPS AND
THE MEDIA, JOURNALISTS AND
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, AMERICAN
MEDIA, FED INTO THIS CAMPAIGN.
THEY WERE UNWITTINGLY BEING USED
BY THE RUSSIANS OVER THE PAST
YEAR.
THAT’S REALLY A SHAME.
THAT’S SOMETHING THEY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN INVESTIGATING FROM THE
BEGINNING.
THIS IS HOW RUSSIAN DOES THIS.
THEY WERE VERY SUCCESSFUL.
>> Sean: TICK-TOCK, THERE’S A
LOT MORE TO COME ABOUT HOW THEY
WERE MANIPULATED.
HOW THEY WERE ENGAGED WITH THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
DR. GORKA MY FAVORITE IS THE DAY
THEY HAD A PRO TRUMP RALLY AND
ANTI-TRUMP RALLY IN THE SAME
CITY ON THE SAME DAY.
SPEAKS VOLUMES.
>> WHAT THEY DO, THAT’S WHAT
THEY DO, THEY DISRUPT OTHER
PEOPLE’S DEMOCRACIES.
BE CLEAR WHAT HAPPENED TODAY,
SEAN.
13 RUSSIANS WERE DIETED AND
THREE -- INDICTED AND THREE
LEGAL ENTITIES.
NOTHING IS GOING ON HAPPEN
THEY’RE RUSSIANS, WE CAN’T
EXTRADITE THEM.
I HAVE A TIP FOR ROBERT MUELLER.
OTHER PEOPLE MESSED WITH OUR
ELECTIONS, AND THEY’RE RIGHT
HERE IN AMERICA.
IT’S HILLARY CLINTON.
THERE’S THE DNC.
THE FUSION GPS.
AND HILLARY’S LAWYER.
THEY MESSED WITH THE ELECTION.
THEY STOLE THE CANDIDACY FROM
BERNIE SANDERS AND THEN THEY
GAVE FALSE INFORMATION TO A FISA
COURT.
MR. MUELLER, IF YOU WANT TO
ACTUALLY PUT SOME PEOPLE IN
PRISON, START WITH THE AMERICANS
THAT PERVERTED OUR ELECTION HERE
IN AMERICA.
>> NOT ONLY THAT, TO DAMAGE, THE
DAMAGE TO THE BUREAU.
AND TO THE BUREAU’S REPUTATION.
THAT PEOPLE WITHIN THE FBI, NOW
WE KNOW, WE’VE SEEN CLEAR
EVIDENCE OF THAT, PETER STRUK,
LISA PAIGE, JAMES BAKER, GENERAL
COUNSEL, PEOPLE WITHIN THE FBI
WHO HAD AN AGENDA.
THAT WAS NOT THEIR ROLE.
NOT THE POLIT BUREAU, NOT
RUSSIA.
THIS APPEARS TO BE HOW IT WAS
RUN.
>> Sean: McCABE AND COMEY AND
STRZOCK AND LORETTA LYNCH AND
PAIGE HAD AN AGENDA?
YOU MEAN THEY EXONERATED
HILLARY?
I CAN’T WAIT FOR THE I.G. REPORT
TO COME OUT.
IF THE I.G. DOES HIS JOB, THAT
MEANS THE FIX WAS, IN THE
PROCESS WAS SCREWED AND IT WAS
SET UP AND RIGGED FROM KAY ONE.
>> WE DON’T HAVE TO EXTRADITE
THEM.
>> I HAVE TALKED TO FOUR FORMER
FBI OFFICIALS CLOSE CONTACT WITH
CURRENT FBI AGENTS.
AND THEY, THE RANK AND FILE ARE
ANGRY.
THEY’RE NOT ANGRY AT THE MEDIA,
THEY’RE ANGRY AT JAMES COMEY,
ANDREW McCABE, STRZOK, PAIGE,
THE WHOLE GANG.
HIGH OFFICIALS IN MANAGEMENT AT
THE PHISH.
SOME OF THE DEPARTMENT OF THE
JUSTICE.
WHO HAVE SHREDDED THE GOOD NAME
AND HARD WORK OF THE PEOPLE WHO
DO THE REAL JOB AND CARRY A
BADGE AND GUN AND TRY TO PROTECT
OUR LIVES.
>> Sean: WE ARE GETTING TO THE
TRUTH IN PART WITHOUT REVEALING
SOURCES AND METHODS TO USE A
PHRASE OF LATE, BECAUSE OF
HONEST FBI GUYS.
HONEST PEOPLE IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
SARA, I KNOW WHO OUR SOURCES ARE
IN SOME CASES.
DR. GORKA AS YOU LOCK AT THIS
AND, WHERE DO YOU THINK THIS
MUELLER IS GOING?
I SEE A GUY THAT IS BLIND IN HIS
AMBITION, THAT HAS HIRED A TEAM
OF DNC OBAMA HILLARY SICPHANTS
OUT TO DESTROY THE PRESIDENT.
>> ROBERT MUELLER, IS KWORTED BY
HIS BOSS ONLY BUDDY, ROD
ROSENSTEIN, WENT TO THE TIME-OUT
TO INTHER VIEW AS DIRECTOR OF
THE FBI WITH PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP.
HE FAILED.
HE DIFFERENT GET THE INTERVIEW.
THE NEXT DAY, ROD MAKES HIM
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR, SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
DON’T YOU ANY HE’S GOT AN
AGENDA?
ABSOLUTELY.
THIS IS REVENGE FOR ROBERT
MUELLER.
BUT WE CAN’T LET HIM PERVERT
JUSTICE LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE ON
THE SEVENTH FLOOR.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT ANDREW
WEISSMANN, GOT BEATEN BY THE
SUPREME COURT OVERTURNED 9-0 IN
THE FIFTH CIRCUIT COURT OF
APPEALS, THIS PIECE, SARA, THIS
GUY TWICE HAS WITHHELD EVIDENCE
IN CASES AND THIS IS WHAT THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" DESCRIBES AS
MUELLER’S PIT BULL?
WHY IS HE THERE?